so this is on the ApS side machine and
apart from the fact that this is an AP
that's all you look that's all they give
you which is a little mystifying because
um yeah this very little to go off okay
also it's tricky because it doesn't say
like you know how simple should you get
it so after we gonna do some work you
might think Oh am I done
I don't know so let's see what we can
start with it's an AP okay so I could
start to deduce some things from these
two statements which is really all I've
got
if it's an AP this line says the case
terms equal P and this says the P term
is equal to K okay so if it's an AP it
should fit it has a sine term and then
you go from term to term there's a
common difference so let's go after this
slide okay this implies that P is equal
to what what's the K term right so I
start with the first term which I don't
know what it is and what do I have to
add puts the K term I have to add K
minus one lots off of the difference and
I don't know what the difference is
either right so I've got K minus one
what's it the difference it's not much
more to do they're three messages you
got one two three four hundreds so
you're sort of probably secretly hoping
you're gonna have some more equations
here you can use to simplify this out
from here we can make the same sort of
statement but it's it's a little
different because of the different
positions of the daddy so this implies K
is equal to again the first term plus in
this case P minus one lots of the
difference okay all right now that's
sort of your basic start now what's your
instinct as to where to go next what
could you do kind of options that you
got yeah we can consider these two
equations simultaneously now like I said
before there are four variables and I've
only got two equations
okay so I shouldn't expect it out of
this I'm gonna know the value of
everything but I might be able to get
the value of some things okay now you
know when you got some taste equations
you can do lots of different things to
simplify them what do you thinks the
best step here yeah she probably
subtract one from the other
right I'm multiplying we're adding isn't
really going to make you things any
simpler okay so I'm going to take
equation 2 subtract equation 1 and let's
see what we get okay
now why would this be a good way to go
because you can see there's a variable
you can get real straight away okay so
that's simplify things let's deposit so
2 minus 1 that'll give you K minus P is
equal to the a is cancelled and then I
have these two parts in the right hand
side P minus 1 lots of D okay laughs I
want to be gross so let's try to expense
that's it well yeah
- I know madam this right
hey D plus D is that right look okay so
far yeah I miss you something this
doesn't look right something's
something's up there it'd be because I
don't know moment these are vanishing oh
no no that is okay those these are
intimate right so I've got rid of my age
I'm confusing with some um can get rid
of those two DS okay
and then I've got PD - KD which I can
take a factor out it's I've got D and
silent P - K
and I've got K men speaking okay yeah
that's sort of nice it's sort of
coincidental at the moment because P
minus K is really the same thing as K
minus P the factor of -1 right so if I
divide both sides by P minus K then I'll
have DB to the negative 1 said okay all
right so that that's kind of convenient
no what can i what can I do with this
okay well if you like me the next thing
I thought was I'm done with equations 1
& 2 so I want to start moving on to this
party right the part they are asking for
okay in exactly the same way as I have
these two statements the K plus P term
right is the first term plus what how
many what's the difference
yeah capo speed that's my that's my n if
you like minus one and lots of the
difference and I know what the
difference is okay so what's like a
minus one there on the end okay so
that's a plus K minus P plus one okay
you might get to that point and think
well am I am I done
is that it there's no the factorizing
note what else can I do
right when not done how would you know
that you're not done you've got a couple
of alternatives firstly you could take
this idea and you could bring it back to
these equations 1 & 2 okay and they
would show you something which I'm going
to show you in a second okay
but another way you could work out that
I should be able to go together here
it's just a bigger what are some
examples of actual kinds of ApS that fit
this right so let's have a theme it is
suppose I have an AP and the second term
is equal to under say 5 ok so that's my
K in my page I should be able to say
from this therefore the fifth term
should be equal to 2 right and this is
just one example of the first two
statements okay
now let's have a look at this you can
see that does imply this right I've gone
for with three terms and I've lost three
right so that's why there's a difference
of minus one okay now hold on a second
what is I would take now the K plus P
term okay in this case that would be two
plus five that's the seventh term okay
well I'm gonna go five I've got four and
three in the middle here there too now
if I want to go another two terms I'm
gonna go to one zero now that seems kind
of weird kind of strange let's see if if
we go with some different numbers okay
what will happen let's suppose we know
the 10th term okay and it's equal to
a what okay and then we swap that around
okay is that right now even though I've
written it in a different way you can
see the same things happening there's
still a difference of minus one as I go
from the first term to the tenth term
I'm going ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one okay what's 2k plus P
it's the 11th term right the one after
this so I have to go minus 1 again okay
now that's starting to get suspicious
right what do they say two times as a
coincidence three times an act of war
something like that so clearly something
is going on and you can yeah we're
nestled in okay DEFCON three oh I don't
know what that means this [ __ ] this one
gives us a good that I should be able to
go further here okay so how can I make
that equal to this I need to get rid of
some of my barriers right so you sort of
only have these two equations to start
off with so I'm going to take my
difference and bring it back to one of
these equations okay so I'm going to
solve D into equation 1 okay it doesn't
matter which one you choose because can
you see they're both really the same
equation just with lettuce one so when I
put in two one I've got P is equal to
the first term plus K minus 1 times
minus 1 minus K and yes even though it
doesn't seem like I've gone very far
this is actually useful to me because I
can let's call this one a by the way you
could call it equation 3 if you like but
when you doing simultaneous equations
particularly you've got a lot of them I
think it's helpful for you to name them
after something just to prevent yourself
from something and back into itself
because then you just get 0 because
you're or 1 equals 1 or something
trivial like that you think
yes that's true that doesn't help me
okay so that's one claim or name I'm
gonna sub1a
into here
okay so if I substitute in one a foot
pain is my P that's the subject I've got
a minus K minus that plus one okay and
now you can see because we sort of
already know where we're going right
what we're expecting I've got a minus k
plus one
yeah and I'm subtracting a minus k plus
1 that's 0 okay and that's as far as you
can go you really got some fun ok so
just to conclude it's a weird question
it sort of throws us because it's so
general right and also because when you
get to this point you're not sure if
you're done this is a helpful strategy
this is not enough to say therefore 10 K
plus P is equal to 0 but it can nudge
you in the right direction to see that
okay I shouldn't just stop